We knew that the web was the wrong
architecture for economic activity long
before Mythos.
That is why we built grids, Gajumaru
remote instruction dispatch and
serialization,
a dead drop signature protocol that
removes the attack surface entirely.
The credentials are never on the
connected system. There is nothing to
find because the sensitive data was
never placed there.
I am going to show you this at work
right now.
Here we have Gaju Desk,
a built-from-scratch zero-dependency
interface for the Internet of Economics,
installed on my desktop. You can see my
wallet,
my Gaju balance,
my account ID,
and the grids URL field at the bottom.
That is how we authenticate and sign. No
username, no password, no web socket. It
operates from the device's secure
enclave.
That means the private keys never leave
the signing context and never touch the
connected layer.